for real that you have a lot of tattoos
what are your tattoos I do this is a
Hawaiian tattoos like a normal cool so
this is a shark the mono is my protector
and then this is from my grandfather
only a hot man can pull up a scrunchie
I'm just rocking a pink scrunchie like
what's it like to be you just walk it
everywhere I like pink I like pink I
don't know I do you look great but I'm
just saying not everyone not every man
out there if we said hey every man out
there right now just walk out some paint
put a scrunchie on it's gonna look
different it's gonna look you're blessed
all these men are blessed it's amazing
no I did see something though I know you
have tattoos but I saw an SNL recently
you had to wear something else on your
chest did that hurt oh yeah
yeah I've never had my nipple glued on
to my nipple before so yeah norwalk how
about were my moms like in horror she's
just there like
[Applause]
do you always cuz every picture I see
you in you always look like you work out
all day like do you always work don't
tell me this do you is this natural is
this genetics like a whole I don't I
don't I'm not a fan of working that well
we work out so much like Aquaman it's
it's all the time and so when we're done
I haven't touched a weight since we
wrapped which is like two and a half
years ago it's just survived such a
blessing do you eat really healthy no
[Applause]
I'm not like a sweets fan oh I love
cheese oh I love cheese and wine yeah I
talk to report yeah yeah yeah that old
thing careful assault Beth yes no I love
that you brought your mom to SNL though
has she ever been starstruck does she oh
yeah she's I'm I'm the same way that I
get I don't you I don't know I do a toy
I think it's sad when you're not like
that absolutely lost that like childlike
like oh my god it's exciting huh yeah
yeah I heard that you my favorite thing
is I saw a picture of you was it Barbra
Streisand yeah I my mom raised me on I
love Barbra Barbra Streisand the same
birthday it's not fair she's she's
amazing we're at the Oscars and I turned
around and she's like hello Jason I'm
like oh my god she said your name
leaking out every Babs knows my name can
leave I just I just kept thinking my
mom's gonna go oh my god I'm always here
my moments you grew up let's say to her
like Christmas doesn't start until that
album comes out like it's an amazing
album you didn't know her I love her the
best person yeah I mean one of the
greatest singers actors all time yeah
she's so great you just met Clint
Eastwood to write recently just left
yeah yesterday wow what was that well is
it real quiet
that's a meadow he smiled Dukes I was
like oh my kids get over here now
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this